il est 16h30 bienvenue en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour une édition
spéciale deux prises d'otage sont
actuellement en cours en Île-de-France
une à dmartin angouel en cemarne c'est
là que sont retranchés depuis ce matin
shérif et Saïd Kashi les deux suspects
de l'attaque au siège de Charlie abdo
qui a eu lieu mercredi faisant 12 morts
et puis la deuxième prise d'otage elle
est en cours depuis 13h porte de 20
scènes à Paris au moins 5 personnes
serait retenu en otage et l'homme
suspecté d'être l'auteur de cette prise
d'otage est le même que celui de la
fusillade qui a eu lieu hier à euh
Montrouge cet homme a été identifié
amedi Koulibali la préfecture de police
de Paris a lancé un avis de recherche le
concernant avis de recherche qui a été
également lancé pour la compagne de
celui-ci ayat bouédienne si vous
disposez de la moindre information les
concernant un numéro
080502 17 17 alors durant plus d'une
heure nous allons revenir sur ces
derniers événements les commenter les
analyser et bien sûr vous faire vivre en
direct tout ce qu'il se passera avec nos
invités en plateau Jean-Marc Bayol
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire général du
syndicat des cadres de la sécurité
intérieure et notre chroniqueur Michel
zames bonjour Michel bonjour il était
13h porte de 20 scènes lorsqu'une
fusillade a éclaté faisant au moins deux
morts à l'heure actuelle je vous le
disais une prise d'otage est toujours en
cours au moins C personnes seraient
retenu en otage le point sur la
situation porte de Vincenne avec Quentin
calm
recul vers 13h un homme tire plusieurs
fois à l'arme automatique devant un
supermarché cacher avant de se
retrancher à l'intérieur avec plusieurs
otages dont des femmes et des enfants le
quartier de la porte de Vincenne est
alors intégralement bloqué les policiers
en civil arrivés les premiers sont
remplacés par des hommes des forces
spéciales déployés en très grand nombre
et lourdement armé au même moment la
préfecture de police publie cet avis de
recherche il s'agirait du même homme
qu'à Montrouge hier ahedi Koulibali 32
ans des sources proches de l'enquête ont
confirmé un lien avec les frère Kashi
les tueurs de charlibdo les trois hommes
se seraient rencontrés au sein de la
filière djihadiste desb chumon amedi
Koulibali pourrait même être le
troisième assaillant de l'ebdomadaire
satirique la police recherche également
activement une jeune femme Hayat boméien
la compagne de Coulibali à Vincen les
forces de police sont regroupées tout
autour du magasin cacher la situation
semble figée depuis plusieurs heures
dans une ambiance de grande tension tu
m'app et on va tout de suite porte de
Vincenne où se trouve Thomas soulier
bonjour Thomas vous êtes sur place alors
quelles sont les informations dont vous
disposez et bien nous sommes ici auien
seulement environ 500 m de l'épicerie
Cachard c'est ici que les forces de
l'ordre nous ont placé nous journalistes
pour éviter de nuire à leur travail
évidemment le quartier est totalement
bouclé deux stations de métro de la
ligne une du métro sont fermées
actuellement et puis le périphérique a
été fermé également à hauteur de la
porte de Vincen alors peu d'information
nous parviennent les policiers gendarmes
sont très silencieux les informations
qui nous parviennent et bien sont à
mettre évidemment à l'heure où je vous
parle au conditionnel cinq personnes
seraient encore retenu dans lespisseries
cachè et puis le prur d'otage pourrait
être et je dis bien pourrait être Amidi
Coulibali l'assassin de la policière de
Montrouge des informations qui n'ont
toujours pas été
confirmées merci beaucoup Thomas et on
vous retrouve bien sûr dès que vous
disposez de la moindre information alors
Jean-Marc Bayel sur cette prise d'otage
à
Vincen on comprend bien sûr que vous ne
puissiez pas donner toutes les
informations néanmoins quelles sont les
informations dont vous disposez vous et
que vous pouvez nous communiquer bah les
informations c'est que suite à la
nouvelle prise d'otage qui est for lié à
la à la première je crois que les choses
sont établies le raid s'est déplacé sur
les lieux après que le périmètre a été
sécurisé il y aurait donc des des
preneurs d'otage deux au minimum qui
seraient donc à l'intérieur et qui ont
plusieurs otages dont on ne peut bien
entendu pas donner de nombre et là
forcément on est dans la phase de de de
de sécurisation de travaill habituel des
forces de l'ordre pouror en quoi
consiste précisément cette phase de
sécurisation est-ce que vous pouvez nous
l'expliquer bah c'est d'abord c'est un
message que je passe face à la
population il faut bien entendu que
l'ensemble des des des citoyens restent
chez eux ne sortent pas ne viennent pas
voir en en spectateurs qu'on fasse
confiance à aux forces de l'ordre qui
depuis de jours ont montré leur
détermination et leur efficacité pour
pour identifier d'abord les auteurs vous
avez cité les les noms il y a le lien
entre les deux binômes puisque c'est
aussi une particularité et une
particularité aussi par rapport à
d'autres prises de d' Tage et que à
d'autres situations similaires c'est que
là il y a prise d'otage donc ça veut
dire que les interventions vont être
forcément différente qu'un simple
forcené qui serait chez lui voilà donc
il a il y a préservation forcément des
otages l'essentiel c'est la priorité des
forces de l'ordre aussi et si possible
peut-être qu'on en reparlera des auteurs
pour que on puisse avoir un jugement
démocratique et mettre cette
problématique sur la place publique aux
yeux du monde parce que c'est un vrai
phénomène et cette barbarie politique
doit se doit vraiment d'être enrayée par
tous les moyens possibles et et et le
procès peutre être un des moyens qui
peut y remédier ça veut dire que quoi
qu'il arrive il faut tout faire pour
prendre ses otages vivants bien bien sûr
c'est c'est bien sûr les otages doivent
être les otages doivent être présés les
preneurs d'otage il y a il y a il y a il
y a ce qu'on peut penser comme policier
he qui a été atteint lorsque on a vu
comment ça s'est passé pour l'un des
nôtres et avec les risques potentiels
qui sont encore là de se dire que
finalement ces
gens-là et je parlerai à titre personnel
mérite-il vraiment de de vivre
maintenant en tant que citoyen et répu
Iain il faut effectivement qu'on puisse
les intercepter pour faire toute la
lumière et que quelque part on puisse
publiquement avoir un jugement qui qui
qui caractérise avec une nécessité c'est
que le législateur et en a ici au Sénat
prenent en compte cette cette
spécificité cette évolution dans dans la
crimin dans la criminalité de ce type
pour queon adapte aussi nos lois à cette
ces particularités dans l'avenir mais
c'est pas le sujet le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est de sauver le maximum de vies euh
par parce que voilà il y en a déjà eu
trop de perdu et et c'est traumatisant
pour pour tout le monde
Michel ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est
que c'est c'est une première en France à
Paris maintenant en région parisienne
c'est la première fois que la France est
confrontée à ce phénomène une double
prise d'otage par les terroristes
évidemment ce qui s'est passé à Charlie
Hebdo et maintenant ce qui se passe en
région parisenne en cymar ce qui se
passe porte de Vincen c'est la première
fois et là aujourd'hui vous parlez du
législateur vous parlez de l'exécutif
l'exécutif a un rôle majeur à jouer
c'est que c'est lui qui va donner
l'ordre à un moment donné de donner
l'assaut ou pas en fonction de des
décisions de la police bien évidemment
et là c'est un rôle majeur c'est un rôle
c'est une décision très très importante
majeure pour pour le président de la
République car c'est lui qui va donner
l'ordre à un moment donné et c'est vrai
que là on est dans un moment jamais
jamais jamais vu en France à ce
niveau-là en tout cas on se rappelle de
prise d'otage vous en rappelez
certainement évidemment à ne de de cette
école maternelle on se rappelle
peut-être de la fermera mais la fermerra
c encore différent vous le rappelez
parce que c'était un homme qui était
seul chez lui et donc le raid à l'époque
je crois que c bien le raid qui qui
avait agi il y avait eu évidemment des
des forces de l'ordre qui avaent été
touché là cas totalement nouveau pour
pour la France et pour la police
peut-être vous allez peut-être nous le
dire effectivement si la la comparaison
avec la fermera doit rappeler à tout le
monde que il ne faut pas confondre le
temps politique avec le temps de
l'intervention et dans ce genre de
situation il faut savoir prendre le
temps pour vraiment atteindre l'objectif
à savoir sécuriser garantir le maximum
de vie je le rappelle des otages des
policiers bien entendu et et et des des
mises en cause si l'intervention le
permet la fermera c'est complètement
différent même s'il y a des similitudes
dans la façon d'agir qui sont quand même
assez troublantes hein dans dans dans
les objectifs la sérénité le calme des
auteurs on a pu le voir sur les
différentes images mais il était seul
chez lui et il s'est cantonné pendant
plus de 30 HE euh enfermé donc on peut
pas comparer de situations et et
forcément si les forces de police du
raid là en l'occurrence et GIGN dans le
encenemarne sont entraînés habitués à
genre d'intervention euh là la grosse
différence et c'est une nouvelle aussi
différence avec Mera c'est que c'est
deux binômes qui sont en lien donc c'est
c'est la première fois que le GN et le
raid travaillent ensemble oui comment ça
se passe justement bah là en
l'occurrence ils ont travaillé ensemble
jusqu'à hier soir puisque jusqu'à ce
matin puisque ils étaient ensemble sur
le le le le sud de looise et et le nord
de laassénémarne là la situation
nouvelle de de 13h a fait que le raid
s'est déplacé effectivement sur la porte
de Vincen pendant que le GIGN reste mais
bon il y a donc ça veut dire que là les
hommes du Raid ne sont plus euh ne sont
plus à damartin angouel où sont
retranchés les frères co ou il y a
largement assez d'effectifs et là aussi
c'est c'est une façon de de montrer à la
population que pour ces forces d'élite
il y a il y a les moyens et encore
beaucoup de réserves pour pouvoir faire
face à l'événement la le périmètre c'est
les policiers les gendarmes du secteur
et après l'intervention c'est les gens
du raid du du G GN du GPN pourquoi pas
en renfort donc il y a le raid est venu
parce qu'effectivement c'est important
d'avoir deux forces hyper spécialisées
qui sont en lien entre elles mais voilà
la la la grande différence ça va être ce
ce ce lien alors qu'ils n'ont peut-être
pas entre eux he par des moyens
téléphoniques ou autes peut-être on sait
pas ça bien entendu mais de de de savoir
que les deux affaires sont lier et que
il va falloir faire les choses dans la
dans dans les meilleures conditions
possibles toujours jour je le répète
pour préserver les vies mais ça prouve
aussi que cette attaque était préparée
visiblement si on comprend mieux un peu
tout ça pas ces attaques précise
aujourd'hui et cette prise d'otage mais
en tout cas la France attaquée ça
c'était sûr et certain c'est une équipe
construite c'est une équipe qui
s'entraîne depuis des années et des
années visiblement si on refait un peu
le parcours de de ces personnalités sont
jeunes une trentaine d'années à tout
cassé et et pourtant ils sont été
entraîner ils arrêtent pas visiblement
selon les témoignages de de parler de de
d'Al-Qaïda au yémenqïa Yémen c'est pas
les jeunes qui partent en Syrie
aujourd'hui pour combattre Al-Qaïda au
Yémen c'est des gens qui étaient proche
de la cellule Al-Qaïda donc de de du
d'Al-Qaïda historique si on peut dire ce
qui n'a rien à voir c'était des équipes
bien préparées qui sont partis
s'entraîner et certainement aussi
visiblement de ce que l'on sait qui sont
partis aussi vers l'Algérie et
visiblement là aussi des informations
émanent comme quoi l'Algérie aurait
prévenu la France il y a quelques jours
qu'une attaque était en préparation sur
la 6 janvier visiblement selon les
informations attention pron a beaucoup
de prudence bien évidemment mais si
c'était vrai et que la France était au
courant qu'il allait y avoir des
attaques on était certainement préparé
la France s'est préparée depuis des mois
et le savait très bien qu'il y avoir
certainement des attaques mais là aussi
il y aura quand même encore des
questions on n'est pas encore là mais il
y aura quand même des questions à se
poser vous évoquez he Michel le profil
de ces preneurs d'otage on va se pencher
sur l'un d'entre eux amedi Koulibali
identifié il y a quelques heures euh
dont le signalement a été communiqué par
la préfecture de police de Paris il est
suspecté de la fusillade à Mont-Rouge et
de la prise d'otage en cours porte de
Vincen Faustine saint-jeuniè bonjour que
sait-on sur le profil de cet homme et
bien amedi Coulibali a 32 ans il est né
à juvisi surorge dans les sones son
profil et bien c'est un ancien voyou
converti à l'islam radical au total il a
été condamné à plus de 18 ans de prison
il en est sorti il y a à peu près 1 an
il a été plusieurs fois condamné pour
vol aggravé dès 2001 à l'époque il était
encore mineur il est d'ailleurs passé
devant la cour d'assis pour mineur en
2004 il est Cope à l'époque de 6 ans de
prison à sa sortie de prison et bien on
l'imagine ranger en réalité il a basculé
dans l'islam radical il s'est converti à
l'islam à Fleury Merogis fleur Merogis
où il rencontre d'ailleurs shérif Kashi
l'un des deux auteurs de la tuerie de
Charlie Hebdo mercredi matin il le
rencontre entre 2005 et 2006 les deux
hommes se connaissent donc très bien il
gravide d'ailleurs autour du même
prédicateur Jamel bégal qu'on a déjà
évoqué ici hier il a été condamné pour
terrorisme et c'est un prosélite reconnu
il est aussi à fleur Merogis à la même
époque alors les deux hommes ahedi
Koulibali comme sherif kwashi sont
arrêtés en 2010 par la police
antiterroriste on les soupçonne d'avoir
participé à un projet d'évasion d'une
figure de l'islam radical un des
principaux auteurs de la vague
d'attentat dans le métro et le RER
parisien en 1995 pour le compte du GIA
algérien alors sherif kwashi sans sor
ira avec un non lieu faute de preuve en
revanche et bien ahedi Coulibali aura
des perquisitions à son domicile en 2010
il estcera de prison on aura retrouvé
une centaine de cartouches chez lui
ainsi que des recharges de kalashnikov
il est sorti de prison depuis à peu près
an merci beaucoup Faustine pour toutes
ces précisions alors Jean-Marc bayul on
entendait Faustine nous dire que le lien
est établi entre les frères kouashi et
amedi Koulibali euh finalement ce ne
sont pas deux hommes isolés qui visaient
simplement le siège de Charlie Hebdo
mais un groupe qui préparait des
attaques de plus grande ampleur euh
c'est c'est pour ça que en terme de de
de communication sur les fait notamment
euh les fait euh liés à la à la au
meurtre de la policière municipale la
stagiaire policière municipale dans le
sud de Paris euh il fallait être prudent
et avoir des des garanties parce que on
a des signalements eu un recoupement et
et l'enquête a a rapidement euh établi
effectivement ce ce lien d'abord
l'identité
ce lien et et et et le fait
queeffectivement ce n'est peut-être pas
les jeunes dont on parlait tout à
l'heure mais qui sont certes entraînés
et qui ont une détermination d'atteindre
des cibles qui sont les cibles mêmes du
fondement de notre République
c'està-dire la liberté de la presse ce
qui représente la sécurité et l'ordre et
ici une une épicerie cachère donc il y a
pas d'ambiguïé sur le fait qu'il y a une
similitude aussi avec l'affaire
l'affaire
mer puisque les cibles étaient aussi les
représentants de l'État les militaires
et une école israélite donc ce qu'il
faut c'est c'est c'est vrai que on a des
médias aujourd'hui qui sont là 24h/ 24
minutes par minute et je crois qu'il
faut savoir raison garder pour prendre
du recul en tout état de cause ne pas
rentrer dans la moindre polémique
maintenant il était fait allusion à une
éventuelle information de l'Algérie mais
je je je prie de de penser que des
informations comme ça il do arriver
souvent tous les jours et que elles ne
sont pas forcément d'une d'une précision
qui va dire qu'il doit attaquer tel jour
telle heure à tel endroit c'est toute la
problématique dans dans dans dans la
façon de faire le renseignement faudra
sûrement tirer des conclusions je le
disais tout à l'heure par rapport à au
suivi de ces individus notamment le fait
qu'il est fait de la prison avec le
passé qu'il avait l'endoctrinement
évident dont il avait fait l'objet
est-ce qu'on doit pas faire des lois
spécifiques pas d'exception mais
spécifiques par rapport à cette nouvelle
criminalité qui qui fait face à nous et
qui monte en puissance et et vous disiez
tout à l'heure euh euh certes
l'information était pas forcément fiable
de de de d'Algérie et je je dis ça de
façon très très généraliste pour autant
nos hommes politiques le ministre de
l'Intérieur n'a eu cess depuis des mois
de monter en puissance sur des messages
de prudence que le risque augmentait et
queil fallait être vigilant ça provient
que l'ensemble des services de
renseignement ont travaillit mais il
faudra sûrement euh dans l'avenir et et
en tout cas on est plusieurs
organisations syndicales de policiers à
demander à qu'on puisse vraiment être
associé à une réflexion pour améliorer
encore l'efficience de nos de nos
service Mel lendemain du 11 septembre
aux États-Unis il y a eu ce qu'on
appelit le le patriotique Act c'est
vraiment c'était des lois d'exception
c'est ce que vous disiez Monsieur B euhy
TER non mais vous dit qu'on on n'était
pas encore à demander des lois
d'exception aux États-Unis c'est ce qui
a été fait sil y a eu un attentat après
c'était l'attentat de
Boston peut-être que en tout cas on sait
qu'une certaine partie de la classe
politique demande C ce genre de loi
notamment une partie des des membres de
l'UMP c'est une vraie question qu'il va
falloir poser au lendemain quand on va
poser un petit peu tout ce qui s'est
passé et regarder un petit peu plus
clairement est-ce qu'il faut agir dans
la précipitation sûrement pas ou garder
il y a une loi antiterroriste qui a été
votter au Sénat il y a pas il y a peu de
temps est-ce qu'elle est suffisante ou
pas d'abord qu'elle soit promulguée et
qu'elle soit promulguée bien entendu on
va en parler he mais nous sommes en
ligne avec Christian Cambon bonjour vous
êtes sénateur du valde Marne un
département limitrophe euh de la porte
de vincè quelle est votre réaction suite
à cette nouvelle prise d'otage écoutez
ma ma réaction elle est à la fois celle
du sénateur et celle du maire je dirais
d'abord celle du maire de saint-maaurice
puisque je suis à quelques kilomètres
euh de l'actuelle prise d'otage de la
porte de Vincen il y a encore euh euh
quelques instants euh je faisais face à
des parents euh excessivement inquiets
alors de la sortie des écoles euh les
enfants ont été confinés toute une
partie de l'après-midi enfin il y a une
véritable euh panique en tous les cas
une très grande peur qui s'empare de la
population puisque finalement trois ou
quatre personnes arrivent à faire en
sorte que la France s'arrête euh Paris
est paralysé les transports sont
suspendus et donc je crois que ces
terroristes atteignent leur but c'est de
nous faire vivre à leur temps et de
faire cesser notre temps donc je crois
que sur ce plan vivant aussi la
proximité d'une telle prise d'otage
c'est quelque chose évidemment de très
inquiétant et puis enant en tant que
sénateur en tant que parlementaire et
membre de la commission de la
défense je je je nourris évidemment ces
événements pour les réflexions futures
car je pense que vous avez raison de
dire qu'il va falloir tirer un certain
nombre de conséquences pas dans le
désordre mais en tous les cas en en en
réfléchissant notamment sur les moyens
qui sont consentis à à la défense
intérieure la défense extérieure nos
relations avec le Maroc qui sont si
mauvaises actuellement alors que c'était
l'un des pays qui fournissait les
meilleurs renseignements au service
français il y a beauoup beaucoup de
questions qui vont se poser après dans
l'union nationale bien sûr mais avec
lucidité concrètement comment on peut
faire pour renforcer notre arsenal
législatif moi je pense pas non plus que
l'accumulation de lois est fatalement
une bonne chose je pense qu'on a déjà un
arsenal législatif assez conséquent je
pense en revanche qu'il faut faire très
attention au moyens parce que vous savez
moi j'ai au titre de la commission j'ai
été voir l'état de nos forces à sangaris
à Bangui et cetera et j'ai vu que euh on
avait besoin de moyens qui soient
satisfaisants notamment en matière de
renseignement hein renseignement humain
renseignement euh technologique je pense
qu'il ne faut pas baisser la pression je
pense qu'il y a des risques qui sont
essentiels il faut aussi faire en sorte
que nos contacts avec les pays amis du
Maghreb où se trame beaucoup de toutes
ces choses et qui servent manifestement
de de de relais euh au Moyen-Orient je
pense qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'initiatives à prendre donc c'est pas
la peine d'avoir des lois
supplémentaires il faut simplement que
ce qui est décidé fonctionne que nos
crédits soient à la hauteur hein j'ai
entendu de beaux esprits qu'on demandait
que on diminue les crédits militaires et
bien j'espère que une vraie prise de
conscience va être effective et queon va
pouvoir comprendre que la France est en
guerre que on fait face à une offensive
terroriste absolument terrible et rien
ne dit que nous en sommes au bout ce
soir bien sûr je souhaite que cela
s'arrête et que euh que que que les que
cette catastrophe nationale et peut-être
européenne cesse mais en tous les cas
tous les pays occidentaux sont menacés
particulièrement la France et je crois
qu'il faut surtout utiliser les moyens
qui sont les nôtres et pas baisser la
garde ne pas baisser la garde Christian
Cambon vous l'avez dit hein vous êtes
maire de saint-maaurice une commune
limitrophe de la porte de Vincenne
quelles sont les mesures concrètes que
vous avez prise cet après-midi dans
votre ville immédiatement j'ai mobilisé
ma police municipal j'ai un effectif de
12 policiers municipaux qui sont en
permanence dans les rues dans une
attitude non pas passive mais
excessivement vigilante par ailleurs
nous avons fait en sorte que les parents
viennent à l'intérieur des écoles
rechercher les enfants alors que au
paravant dans dans dans un bon climat et
la bonne humeur les gens stationnent à
l'extérieur donc nous avons fait en
sorte que tous les rassemblements euh
soient euh dispersé le plus vite
possible que les enfants rentrent très
vite chez eux par ailleurs j'ai obtenu
de la communauté juive de saint-maaurice
qu'elle ne célèbre pas
exceptionnellement ce soir les les les
les offices du shabbat parce
que a il y a des menaces qui courent et
les informations que nous avons nous
demandent d'être excessivement prudent
car rien ne dit qu'il y a pas d'autres
gens qui circulent dans la nature et qui
ont l'intention de continuer cette
offensive donc je pense que c'est la
vigilance c'est la solidarité c'est
l'absence de panique mais le fait que
aussi nous soyons bien attentif moi mes
réseaux de vidéo protection fonctionnent
à plein j'ai une cinquantaine de caméras
tout est à la disposition de la Police
nationale nous sommes en plus sur le
bord de l'autoroute à 4 donc vous
imaginez entre ce qui se passe au nord
de la cénémarne et ce qui se passe à la
porte de vincene toutes nos communes
sont en alerte vous l'imaginez bien
merci beaucoup Christian Cambon merci
d'avoir été avec nous on entendait hein
Christian Cambon parler de cet arsenal
législatif on a entendu manuel Vals
Michel ce matin dire qu'il fallait
peut-être aller plus loin que peut faire
le gouvernement que peut faire le
Parlement manuel Val qui est revenu un
petit peu plus tard en arrière qui a pas
voulu aller plus loin sur cette question
en tout cas aujourd'hui parce que c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être pas le jour
hier on était encore dans le deuil dans
l'hommage aujourd'hui il se passe encore
d'autres événements mais au jour de ces
événementsl c'est vrai qu'il va
peut-être falloir aller plus loin
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit hein la loi
n'est pas encore promulgué la loi sur la
loi contre contre le terrorisme qui a
été votée au Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale n'est pas encore promulgué
mais elle avancé déjà quelques pistes et
chrtian comambon le dit il y a déjà un
arsenal législatif qui est présent
notamment pour empêcher ces jeunes de
partir en Syrie et pour ceux qui
reviennent de leur retirer leur carte
d'identité notamment ces mesures
administratives ça ne va peut-être pas
encore assez loin peut-être que là on
peut poser la question à Monsieur bel
est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire de plus peut-être vous parliez de
d'actes supplémentair on peut vous
demander exactement concrètement ce
qu'il faudrait de plus concernant la loi
qu'a proposé monsieur casenu et qui a
été d'ailleurs votée au-delà de la
majorité gouvernementale ce qui est
quand même un signe euh déjà que sur
cette thématique il y a une unité euh
au-delà des partis et c'est bien la
moindre des choses euh qu'elle soit
promulguée pourquoi je le disais parce
que elle est elle est plutôt bien cette
loi c'està-dire qu'elle effectivement
permet pas mal de choses euh notamment
le principe des pièces d'identité le
principe de remettre en place euh
l'autorisation pour les mineurs c'est de
choses assez simples basique mais qui
sont quand même d'une évidence non je
faisais plutôt allusion moi à à une loi
concernant euh euh qui n'existe pas euh
c'est la loi concernant la détention on
a on le sait et c'est pour ça que je
disais qu' fallait avoir une réflexion
large on sait que beaucoup de ces gens
euh c'est ces criminels je je je
j'arrive pas à trouver un nom forcément
adéquat tellement c'est terrible on
n'est pas dû on n pas du tout à faire à
des braqueurs euh tel qu'on a connu
c'est des terroristes qui euh euh voilà
sont d'une froideur euh donc qui sont
qui est pas comparable à ce qu'on a pu
connaître sur des les grandes époques
même de de de des braqueurs qui tuaient
vraiment par nécessité et non pas
gratuitement
euh beaucoup ont été convertis ou
convertissent d'autres à leurs
idéologies en prison et il faut savoir
il faut se poser la question si en
France on a le le le matériel
pénitentiaire si je puis dire pour
éviter cette contagion alors qu'il se
fait par d'autres moyens les réseaux
sociaux on le sait mais je crois que
tous les spécialistes le contrraur en
général des privations de liberté euh
des analyses et cetera ont prouvé queil
y avait dans dans les prisons cette
problématique euh un petit peu comme aux
États-Unis le principe des le problème
des gangs qui se en prison lorsqu'ils
sont détenus convertissent au gang
justement des des des des délinquants on
va dire primaires et je c'est ça nous
notre demande c'est de de de de de faire
le constat et le problème c'est que ça
ne résoudra pas tout malheureusement
puisqu'on voit que ces individus là ils
sont par binôes mais lorsqu'ils sont
seuls c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
forcément à à à anticiper à suivre mais
en tout cas il faudra mettre à plat je
veux pas rentrer dans le détail non plus
faut pas donner toutes nos nos armes à
nos ennemis qui sont peut-être justement
à regarder mais voyez basiquement et on
attend depuis quelques années maintenant
que le le service de renseignement
territorial qui a été mis en place il y
a 2 ans maintenant par Monsieur Vals
puisse avoir enfin un fichier pour
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
fichier qu' n'a toujours pas donc c'est
c'est c'est un peu empirique il
travaille mais c'est une nécessité faut
vraiment que dans ce pays on arrive à à
franchir certaines barrières
idéologiques j'allais dire quelquefis
dogmatique sur le problème des fichiers
et cetera il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
et il faut lutter arm égal face à ces
individus à ces teror si on comprend
bien la loi actuelle qui a été votée est
suffisante à vos yeux il n' fait pas
encore assez notamment sur les prisons
faut rappeler quand même que depuis 1986
il y a eu 66 lois contre les mesures de
terrorisme donc finalement on pe dire
qu'à chaque phénomène et C il y aura une
sur surloi une nouvelle loi encore une
fois surtout pas justement c'est la loi
cas9 voté au-delà de de la majorité
comme je l'ai dit euh est plutôt bien
ressenti par les les les les
spécialistes là je parle du du problème
de la détention bien sû temps avant
qu'elle se MRE en place voilà mais la
détention c'est vrai que c'est la
décision du juge c'est vrai et on peut
pas remettre en cause l'indépendance de
la justice mais pour ces individusl il
faut vraiment qu'on ait une réflexion
parce que il y a un déterminisme qui se
prolonge dans le temps et et la prison
ne résout pas le problème on va on va
revenir là-dessus mais on va regarder
ces images en direct de Dam Martin
angouel dam Martin angouel où son sont
retranché depuis ce matin les frères
kouashi suspectés d'être les auteurs de
l'attaque au siège de Charlie Hebdo on
le voit Jean-Marc Bayel de la fumée qui
s'échappe de l'entrepôt dans lequel sont
retranchés les deux frères kouashi
est-ce que c'est le signe que l'assaut a
été donné à dam Martin angouel peut-être
je je vous me permettrez est-ce que le
l'instant est tour émouvant parce qu''il
y a des collègues qui sont engagé donc
je je je ne sais pas on peut le penser
effectivement puisque euh au niveau de
ce que je je vois c'est des des des gaz
qui sont ou paralysants ou ou
lacrymogène ou d'autres je ne sais pas
maintenant on peut imagin aussi un
incendie bon c'est pour ça que je je je
ne préfère pas me prononcer c'est en
cours et et je je je pense que par c'est
en cours il y a des vies en jeux il faut
permettrait de pas m'exprimer on va bien
sûr rester un très prudent sur ce qu' se
passe là-bas comme sur ce qui se passe
porte de V scène où je veux où je vous
le rappelle deux prises d' ages sont en
cours néanmoins sans nous donner plus
d'infos Jean-Marc Bayol on va bien sûr
rester très
prudent est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer concrètement si l'assaut ceci
dit a été lancé quelle est la chaîne de
commandement Michel le disait tout à
l'heure il y a dans ces cas-là une prise
de décision il y a deux prises d'otagees
actuellement en cours quelle est la
chaîne de commandement qui décide de
donner l'assaut bah il y a pas de règle
forcément établies hein parce que chaque
situation est différente mais là
effectivement on une connexion donc de
toute façon c'est les policiers du GI GN
d'un côté du Raed de l'autre qui sont
les spécialistes qui rendent compte à la
hiérarchie on va dire politique de la
situation et qui sont en capacité de
dire si techniquement ils peuvent opérer
neutraliser avec le maximum de garantie
avec toujours des malheureusement des
impondérable donc c'est pas un policier
qui va décider seul le le chef qui va
décider est seul d'y aller c'estàd que
il il y a quand même des enjeux et des
vies maintenant c'est lui et et le
pouvoir politique va lui faire confiance
de dire oui à ce moment-là vous allez
pouvoir inter oui vous avez le feu vert
pour intervenir parce que vous avez les
les données suffisantes pour garantir le
le le l'intervention dans les meilleures
conditions avec cette particularité de
la connexion avec les deux lieux et qui
forcément change la donne et qui donne
le feu ver final le ministère de
l'Intérieur le président de la
République non franchement je je je je
ne dans cette situation je pense que ça
va être au plus haut au niveau de l'ét
bien entendu euh maintenant c'est le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est le
patron et des forces de de la
gendarmerie et du raid et c'est de toute
façon lui qui directement donnera et pas
le président en direct aux forces de
police évidemment alors selon l'Agence
France press des détonations ont été
entendues sur le site de la prise
d'otage de damartin vous le voyez sur
ces images euh en direct de d'AM Martin
angouel ù je vous le rappelle les deux
frères kouashi soupçonnés d'être les
auteurs de l'attaque à Charlie abdo sont
retranchés depuis ce matin Michel d
maintenant que l'assaut l'assaut est en
cours selon des journalistes et
correspondants sur place qui ont entendu
de nombreuses détonations des tirs
nourris également donc effectivement
l'assut est en cours on ne sait pas
encore ce qui se passe porte de Vincen
effectivement est-ce qu'il va y avoir
concomitence entre ces deux assauts
peut-être pas on va on va voir ça dans
dans les quelques quelques minutes ou
quelques heures en tout cas ce qu'on
peut imaginer en tout cas c'est que pour
les frères Kashi qui sont là à dam
Martin l'assaut qui est en cours a été
certainement ordonné aussi parce que
c'était le moment il y a eu un moment de
fatigue également pour pour ces deux
personnes qui depuis 48 HE sont en sont
dans la nature on imagine que c'était
aussi le moment pour pour attaquer hein
c'est c'est dans dans la stratégie c'est
tout est pris en compte la configuration
des lieux effectivement la fatigue qui
est et qui qui même si ces gens sont
entraînés et que de toute façon un
stress fait que on peut tenir plusieurs
jours sans avoir besoin de dormir mais
voilà ils sont deux donc il faut qu'ils
se coordonn il y a plein d'enjeux il y a
il y a des moyens techniques qui
permettent aussi aux forces de l'ORD de
de voir les choses donc donc voilà donc
un peu plus les choses ils ont des
otages et surtout ils sont deux ce qui
est peut-être plus facile pour eux ils
peuvent tenir plus longtemps c'est vrai
là en l'occurrence ils sont deux donc il
y a un
otage l'entreprise est c'est grande donc
c'est pour ça que je parle de la
configuration des lieux il y a il y a
plein de paramètres qui font que euh si
la décision a été prise euh suffisamment
de de feu vert a été allumé euh pour que
ça se passe dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et je je l'espère
vraiment que les policiers et l'otage
n'auront pas été atteints dans leur
chair à l'occasion de cette intervention
euh pour les pour les autres bon voilà
c'est c'est j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
c'est c'est une autre problématique
sachant qu'ils sont eux-mêmes des fois
dans une dans une volonté euh d'en finir
avant même de commencer par rapport à
justement leur endoctrinement et et et
leur engagement religieux qui est bien
loin de des valeurs euh qu'on partage
alors hein vous le voyez je vous le
rappelle sur ces images en direct de Dam
Martin en Gouel l'assaut selon la FP
l'assaut aurait été lancé par le gignn
euh d'mtin angouel où euh je vous le
disais sont retranchés depuis ce matin
les deux frères kouashi suspecté d'être
les auteurs de l'attaque à Charlie Hebdo
les deux frères Kashi qui étaient
traqués par toutes les polices de France
depuis 48h retour sur cette traque avec
ce sujet de Louis Sibille un état de
siège qui dure depuis 6h et pour
l'instant la situation est figée c'est
là que les frères Kachi se sont
retranchés dans une imprimerie familiale
les unités de la police et de la gendarm
sont toujours sur le qui viv sur ces
photos amateurs on les voit casqués et
armés près de l'entreprise les tueur
présumé aurait pris un ou plusieurs
otages aucune certitude sur ce point
pour l'instant on ne sait toujours pas
qui se trouve encore à
l'intérieur dans le ciel cinq
hélicoptères des super pumades de
l'armée de terre à leur bord des tireurs
d'élite un commercial qui avait
rendez-vous ce matin à l'imprimerie
pense avoir croisé les tueurs
lors que je suis arrivé mon client est
sorti avec une avec une personne armée
qui
s'ester de de la police
euh mon client m'a demandé de de partir
donc je suis parti
et la personne qui s'était présentée
comme étant de la police m'a dit écoutez
partez de toute façon on ne tue pas les
civils un témoin rescapé C impasse final
vient après une longue traque plus de 2
jours après avoir été plusieurs fois
perdu de vue les deux suspects ont de
nouveau été repérés tôt ce matin à une
vingtaine de kilomètres au nord de Paris
il braque une voiture mais son
propriétaire les reconnaît un barrage de
police ils sont aperçus une fusillade
éclate sen suit une course poursuite sur
la Nationale 2 les deux hommes se
refugent à darmattin en goë dans cette
imprimerie une petite entreprise de 5
salariés sur place les habitants ont été
mis en sécurité les écoles sont presque
toutes évacué tout le périmètre est
bouclé les habitants sont retranchés et
les négociations se
poursuivent voilà pour ce qui devrait
être dans les minutes à venir l'épilogue
de cette traac des frères Kashi puisque
selon l'Agence France Presse l'assaut a
été donné par le GIGN à damartin enouel
où étit retranché depuis ce matin les
deux frères frère Kashi Michel
visiblement le dénouement est proche en
tout cas c'est il y a plusieurs
détonations qui a été entendu
simultanément Adam Martin on voit des
hommes également sur le toit on imagine
monsieur Bayel que dans ces cas-là c'est
une coordination du du GIGN sur place on
pratique certainement des tours de des
bombes j'imagine pour détourner aussi de
l'attention des terroristes et et
attaquer simultanément c'est bien ça bah
sur le le site de de du 117 oui
évidemment he il y a il y a tout un un
phénomène de de de mise en place de de
de stress pour les les les les mises en
cause qui qui savent qu' un assaut est
possible mais qui savent pas à quel
moment c'est tout tout l'intérêt de la
chose he euh et de protection les toits
bah parce queon peut arriver par les
toit pour justement peut-être les
maîtriser voilà je bon après sur
l'histoire avec le le la porte de Vincen
c'est une c'est c'est autre chose mais
on on peut bien entendu penser
que il y a des garanties qui ont été
prises pour faire en sorte que si
intervention il y avait lieu dans
77 la porte de Vincen ne soit pas
forcément au courant parce que des
dispositions on été prises pour que les
les preneurs d'otage ne le sachent pas
on le voit sur ces images en direct de
Dam Martin en Gouel un hélicoptère de la
sécurité civile qui vient de se poser à
proximité de l'entrepôt où étaient
retranchés les frères Kashi est-ce que
cela signifie je Marc Bay que l'assaut
est terminé ou on ne peut pas faire de
lien al forcément si vous avez un
hélicoptère qui seose à proximité alors
que depuis de ce matin on demande à ce
que tous les les les avions qui
pourraient passer à proximité n'y soi
pas il y a sûrement forcément une
consigne qui a été donnée donc
effectivement les choses a pu être
sécurisé avec bon voilà des réserves
c'est toujours habituelles mais on peut
le penser de façon
factuelle Michel on le voit toujours sur
ces images en direct alors on va être un
très prudent sur les informations on va
se fier hein à ce que nous dit l'Agence
France press mais il
semblerait selon ses images et selon les
informations dont nous disposons que
l'assaut est été donné et que l'assaut
soit peut-être même terminé à Martin
Angel Mel on va rester vraiment prudent
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des
informations qui nous proviennent via
les réseaux sociaux de journalistes qui
envoient leur leur commentaires et
cetera qui sont sur place et qui disent
le nombre de donations qu'ils ont
entendu ce qu'ils puuvent voir ou pas
par contre ce qu'on peut dire là
actuellement et que ça c'est factuel
c'est qu'il y a une réunion d'urgence
qui a lieu à l'Élysée qui réunit le
Premier ministre le président de la
République le ministre de l'Intérieur
Christian tobira et d'autres ministres
on imagine que la cellule de crise qui a
été place Bovo s'est peut-être
délocalisée à l'Élysée et qu'ils sont en
train de gérer évidemment d'être au
courant seconde par seconde de ce qui se
passe à dam Martin de ce ce qui se passe
porte de Vincenne et que tout est géré
en liaison par l'exécutif et par le
nombreux ministres présents au cours de
cette réunion et que toutes les
décisions se font autour du président de
la République dans son bureau du du
président de la République car tout le
monde est réuni à l'Élysée actuellement
et c'est vrai qu'il y avait tout était
organisé la cellule de crise était
organisée place Bovo on imagine que là
tout s'est déporté vers l'Élysée que
c'est là c'est là le cœur des décisions
qui sont en train d'être prises en
liison bien entendu avec les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain euh Jean-Marc
Bayel est-ce que euh selon les
informations dont vous disposez et que
vous pouvez nous donner est-ce que vous
savez euh si des négociations ont eu
lieu avec les frères Kashi qui sont
retranchés euh depuis euh 7h maintenant
dans cet entrepôt non
euh d'abord si je le savais je je ne le
dirais pas mais ce qu'il faut savoir là
aussi de façon factuelle sur la
méthodologie c'est que de toute façon
c'est dans la technique française il y a
toujours tentative de négociation euh
c'est c'est aussi une différence qu'on a
avec d'autres pays donc on peut penser
qu'il y a eu une une une phase de
négociation et qui est logique qu'elle a
fonctionné ou pas c'est un autre
problème elle a peut-être eu lieu et
malgré tout elle fait aussi partie de de
de de de la stratégie d'ensemble
stratégie d'ensemble mais on peut se
dire aussi qu'avec des des terroristes
fondamentalistes comme on a à faire avec
les frères Kashi on peut se dire que
c'était pres comme vous l'avez dit à
coup d'épé dans l'eau parce qu'on on
imagine qu'il n'allit pas se rendre
aujourd'hui aux forces de l'ordre et
qu'ils veulent aller jusque les à la
main jusqu'au bout non on peut le penser
mais on notera quand même que ils ont
pris en otage ils ont pris pour voler le
leur véhicule ce matin quelqu'un qu'ils
n'ont pas maltraité ils étaent plutôt
calme parce que on voit bien que c'est
des fondamentalistes qui veulent tuer
les gens qui les ont ciblé c'est-à-dire
les représentants de l'État et les
journalistes en l'occurrence et pas un
citoyen pour tuer un citoyen qui ne le
gêne pas forcément dans son action euh
maintenant la négociation euh s'ils
avaient voulu tout de suite arrivver au
martyre ou ou à la fin bah peut-être
qu'on en serait pas là depuis au bout de
48 he ça sera peut-être fait avant ils
sont quand même fu ils se sont cachés
ils ont repartis ils ont voé des
voitures et comme il y a un autre binôme
qui est lié peut-être qu'il y avait dans
dans leurs
exigences un lien entre les deux
affaires et et ça l'enquête le révélera
je présume que bien entendu il y aura
une mission parlementaire sur la
question euh voilà a sûrement une
demande de commission d'enquête qui va
arriver très très rapidement évidemment
est-ce que on peut imaginer que Hedi
Coulibali qui est actuellement le
preneur d'otage supposé porte de
Vincenne soit le 3è homme de l'arttaque
de Charlie abdo alors pour
l'instant il y a pas d'élément probant
qui le qui en atteste qu'il soit
l'auteur de montrrouge oui que
vraissemblablement il soit accompagné de
la deuxième personne recherchée
peut-être euh il est clair que que de
toute façon qui pourra être une femme
euh là aussi des spécialistes se sont
déjà exprimés sur le sujet les femmes
qui sont
fondamentalistes sont tout aussi
déterminé que les hommes donc pour
l'instant pour répondre précisément à
votre question il y a rien aujourd'hui
officiellement qui a permis
contrairement à monrouge de prouver
qu'il était sur l'attaque de de de du
siège de Charli ebdo alors je vous le
rappelle he si vous nous rejoignez
édition spéciale sur les chaînes
parlementaires de prise d'otage sont
actuellement en cours en île-de-fance la
première à dmartin Gouel en samarne où
sont retranchés depuis ce matin les
frères Kashi suspectés d'être les
auteurs de l'attaque contre le siège de
Charlie Hebdo mercredi selon les
informations de l'Agence France Press le
GIGN a donné l'assaut à D Martin angouel
il y a quelques minutes euh nous ne
disposons pas d'autres informations sur
l'issue de cette trassau et puis l'autre
prise d'otage elle a lieu porte de 20
scèes où une fusillade a éclaté aux
alentours de 13h fusillade qui a fait
deux morts au moins cinq personnes
seraient encore à l'heure actuelle
retenu en otage porte de vin scenes par
un homme amedi Koulibali suspecté d'être
donc ce preneur d'otage porte de Vincen
et d'être également comme vient de le
rappeler à l'instant Jean-Marc Bayol
l'auteur de la fusillade qui a eu lieu
hier matin à Montrouge faisant un mort
alors nous allons aller porte de
Vincenne où Thomas soulier se trouve
Thomas je ne sais pas si vous m'entendez
est-ce que vous disposez de nouvelles
informations sur place porte de Vincen
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on on
vient on vient d'entendre vous voyez on
vient d'entendre quatre ou cinq
détonations juste derrière moi et des
coups de feu sont en train d'être tiré
nous sommes ici Orian environ à 500 m de
l'épicerie cachè et on entendu il y a
environ une ou 2 minutes quatre ou cinq
détonations je vous le rappelle et des
coups de feu qui sont en train d'être
tirés ici dans 2èe arrondissement de
Paris nous sommes porte de Vincin pour
l'instant nous avons pas plus de
précision les forces de l'ordre sont
très discrètes c'est silence radio du
côté des forces de l'ordre et vous le
voyez juste derrière moi les secours qui
sont placés qui sont en train de monter
des tentes le quartier est totalement
désert et voilà le silence environ
depuis une minute après je vous le
disais Orian ces détonations et ces
coups de feu que nous avons entendu ici
à 500 m de l'épicerie cacha nous savons
pas toujours pas hein si l'assaut a été
donné OUI ou NON MERCI BEAUCOUP Thomas
pour ces informations depuis la porte de
Vincen vous revenez vers nous bien sûr
he dès que vous disposez de nouvelles
informations Jean-Marc bayul on peut on
peut supposer que l'assaut a été donné
quasi simultanément sur les deux prises
d'otage quasi concomitance à quelques
minutes près hein je je je pense que des
dispositions on été prises pour faire en
sorte que alors on on est en direct hein
de la porte de Vincenne he regardez sur
ces images Jean-Marc bol que vous pouvez
peut-être nous commenter C voit on voit
effectivement des gens qui sont évacués
et tenus par des policiers donc évacués
du du du centre hyper cacher donc
l'intervention a eu lieu et bon voilà
maintenant je je on attend avec
inquiétude le le le résultat de de de
l'intervention par rapport aux otages et
aux policiers bien entendu euh Michell
euh visiblement le dénouement est proche
sur les deux lieux des deux prises
d'otage qui avaient lieu depuis quelques
heures maintenant vous dire que il était
presque temps parce que la France
commence à avoir peur voir très très
peur et c'est vrai que c'était un choc
pour l'ensemble des Français euh sa pas
juste s'il y a d'autres personnes qui
courent dans la nature mais là
aujourd'hui si les frères Kashi et si le
troisème homme supposé ou en tout cas
celui de l'auteur de Montrouge de
l'attaque de Montrouge sont aujourd'hui
intercepté ça sera déjà un bon signe
donné à la population française parce
que si on entend les témoignages depuis
tout à l'heure des problèmes pour aller
chercher les enfants à l'école tout
était bloqué le métro bloqué Paris
assiégé la France attaqué c'est vrai que
ce signe est majeur et l'assaut final
donné et la fin de la traque des terror
c'est aujourd'hui un signal très fort
qui est donné aussi par les forces de
l'ordre par l'exécutif et à partir de
dimanche il sera l'heure encore une fois
d'autre chose c'est-à-dire de de
communier ensemble dans cette grande
manifestation pour rendre un un hommage
et apparemment d'après ce qu'on sait il
y aura des représentants du monde entier
qui risquent de venir et notamment
Angela Merkel qui viendra en France
aussi pour témoigner on n est pas là là
on est la fin de la PR d' Angela Merkel
a été reporté reporté visiblement selon
les informations Angela Merkel viendra
en France pour participer à la
manifestation il y a certainement
d'autres personnalités politiques qui
viendront également européennes et et et
certainement du monde entier mais là
c'est vrai que les images sont très
importantes parce que là on a la fin de
cette traque et c'est peut-être c'est
qui c'est l'image qu'on retiendra ce
soir c'est la fin de la peur qui est en
train de régner sur la ville euh on va
revenir hein sur tout ce qui va se
passer dans les jours à venir notamment
sur cette manifestation dimanche mais je
voudrais qu'on reste Jean-Marc bol sur
ces images en direct de la porte de
Vincenne alors que l'Agence France press
confirme à l'instant que l'assaut a
également été donné porte de Vincen ces
images Jean-Marc Bayol et serait même
terminé porte de Vincen ces images nous
le confirment là aussi on voit euh les
pompiers arrivés très près de la
superette où était du supermarché où
étaient retenus les otage vous nous le
confirmez d'après les images que vous
voyez jean-mart Bayol l'assut semble
être t on a vu il y a 2 minutes des déjà
des des premiers otages qui étaient
évacués par des des policiers supportés
on va dire jusqu'à une ambulance qui est
partie donc ça confirme maintenant voilà
je disais qu'on attendait avec anxiété
bah le le alors on vient d'avoir une
information Jean-Marc Bayol information
de l'Agence France Presse hein puisque
je vous le rappelle que nous allons être
très prudents nous donnons uniquement
les informations de lafp l'agence Fran
presse confirme à l'instant que les deux
frères kouashi auraiit été tué dans
l'assaut à dam Martin donc l'assaut qui
a été donné et les deux suspects
auraient été tués dans cet assaut
Jean-Marc Bayel écoutez moi je je ce qui
m'importe un premier temps c'est je
pense que c'est toute la population qui
c'est l'otage si a pu est en réchappé je
crois que c'est on a pas d'information
pour eux vous l'avez dit il y a des
déterminations déjà personnell au départ
le martyre ou le le kamikas je dire
comme on le veut donc bon voilà on verra
dans quelle circonstances c'est passé
mais je veux dire c'est c'est le libéré
est indemne
voilà l'Agence France Presse deux frères
kouashi tués et l'otage libéré et
indemne selon l'Agence France Presse
c'est l'essentiel c'est l'essentiel que
l'otage soit soit sauvé je crois que
tout le monde l'a compris et puis pour
la porte de Vincen on sait déjà qu'il y
avait des des victimes des tirs de de ce
de 13h quand ça s'est passé ben je voilà
on espère qu'il n'y en a surtout pas
d'autres ça a été très vite très rapide
là l'intervention et et j'espère qu'il
n'y aura pas une nouvelle victime c'est
vrai que c'était assez rapide peutêtre
pas pour damartin mais en tout cas pour
la porte de Vincen depuis 13h il est
17h20 c'est quelque chose d'assez rapide
pour une prise d'otage non ouais mais là
la configuration des lieux était
sûrement différente avec bon plein plein
d'éléments bon c'est c'est un c'est en
rez-de-chaussée il y a beaucoup il y a
des vitres il y a y a il y a plus
d'éléments ce que je veux met vraiment
en avant c'est que bah voilà le le
message qui est passé c'est que vous
l'avez dit he le la détermination a été
là l'unité nationale elle a payé et je
je j'espère vraiment que au-delà des
conclusions qu'on devra tirer il faut
que personne ne polémique sur ces
questions euh s'il y a des victimes
c'est des victimes de trop euh mais face
à ce terrorisme là il faut il faut pas
baisser la garde et et rester uni parce
que l'inverse serait donner vraiment
raison à à ces gens-là nous sommes en
ligne avec Michel aliomarie bonsoir
Michel aliomarie ancienne ministre de
l'Intérieur ancienne ministre de la
Défense on le disait euh selon les
toutes dernières informations l'otage a
l'assaut a été donné dans les deux
prises d'otage les deux frères kouashi
ont été tués quelle est votre première
réaction d'abord c'est une réaction que
pour les victimes des attentats de ces
deux derniers jours pour leur famille et
pour leurs amis euh aussi un sentiment
de soulagement euh notamment je pense
que c'est un remarquable travail des
agents du RA du G que d'avoir réussi à
libérer l'otage à Tam Marie j'espère
qu'il y a le moins de dégâts possible en
ce qui concerne maintenant que la la
porte de de
Vincen et je pense qu'il faut
féliciter les les hommes qui ont pris
tous les risques pour réussir cette
opération qui était une opération
extrêmement délicate du fait des otages
alors selon les les dernières
informations plusieurs otages ont été
libérés porte de Vincen euh vous le
disiez à l'instant ce dénouement c'est
une réussite pour les hommes du RAID et
les hommes du GIGN oui ce ce sont les
troupes d'élite de de la police et de la
gendarmerie je les connais bien je sais
qu'à chaque fois leur priorité c'est
toujours de protéger les otages quand il
y a des otages et donc d'intervenir dans
les conditions de la plus grande
sécurité possible et en même temps de la
plus grande efficacité possible euh
Michel lalummarie vous êtes ancienne
ministre de
l'Intérieur est-ce que selon vous
l'arsenal législative qui est en place
en France actuellement est suffisant ce
au vu de ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
jours écoutez l'arsenal législatif peut
toujours être complété on peut toujours
dire on a une idée supplémentaire mais
il faut être bien conscient d'une chose
c'est que nous ne sommes pas à l'abri du
terrorisme la France c'est l'une des
cibles du terrorisme mais le terrorisme
peut frapper n'importe qui à n'importe
quel moment et n'importe où dans le
monde et et à partir du moment où il
s'agit de terroristes isolés c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que lorsqu'il
s'agit de réseau alors là on sait qu'il
y avait eu des informations parce que
notamment ceux qui ont été apparemment
interpellés en tous les cas neutralisé
Adam Martin était signalé semble-t-il et
ils avaient effectivement fait partie
d'un certain nombre de de réseaux que
dont l'un d'entre eux s'était entraîné
au Yémen qui est l'une des bases
d'entraînement du terrorisme comme il y
en a aussi en Libye et dans un certain
nombre d'autres endroits ceci dit il est
extrêmement difficile quand on a une
fultitude d'informations parce que les
services ont beaucoup d'informations
mais il faut savoir comment utiliser ces
informations choisir la bonne
information et de toute façon il peut y
avoir toujours l'élément de
l'incertitude sur la date ou sur le lieu
donc il est évident que toutes les
précautions doivent être prises ceci dit
il faut que chacun soit bien conscient
que nous vivons maintenant avec le
terrorisme et que il faut qu'il y ait
une mobilisation générale contre le
terrorisme ce qu'il faut c'est à la fois
des actions de sécurité que on vient
enen voir certaines la loi peut servir à
cela aussi on peut la compléter mais il
faut également lancer un message très
fort aux terroristes et au groupes
terroriste parce que il faut savoir
qu'il s'agisse de daesh qu'il s'agisse
d'AKM qu'il s'agisse d'al-qïda ce sont
des des groupes don dont le but est
d'impressionner ce qu'ils veulent c'est
faire de la communication et et par
conséquent ils cherchent à faire des
opérations spectaculaire pour essayer de
faire peur et nous devons montrer que
nous n'avons pas peur d'où l'importance
effectivement des manifestations du
dimanche où le message qui doit être
passé c'est celui que le peuple français
tout entier euh ne bassera jamais les
les bras et n'est pas prêt à à se
laisser impressionner intimider euh par
B gens qui liit nos valeurs euh Michel
alomarie euh vous parliez hein à
l'instant de cette nouvelle forme de
menace ce ne sont plus des groupes
organisés euh mais ce sont des individus
solitaires comment on peut lutter
concrètement contre cette nouvelle forme
de menace alors c'est effectivement ce
qui est euh une des nouveautés euh que
je ferai remonter à 4 ou 5 ans si vous
voulez il continue à y avoir des groupes
organisés euh ça il faut savoir et ces
groupes sont suivis par tous les
services et il est évident que nous
voyons comment les les groupes
islamistes les dirigeants islamistes
utilisent notamment Internet pour faire
passer un certain nombre de messages qui
vont influencer des esprits fragiles
parce que c'est cela ce qu'il vivent ce
sont des des gens qui ont des des
faiblesses psychologiques et qu'ils vont
essayer d'endoctriner et quand on voit
que sur Internet dans le même temps il y
a
également des euh il y a également des
sites dans lesquels on vous montre
comment faire une bombe par exemple il
est évident qu'il faut intervenir dans
ce domaine alors moi quand j'étais
ministre de l'Intérieur j'avais essayé
d'agir notamment au niveau européen et
au niveau international parce que ça ne
peut pas être simplement l'affaire d'un
d'un pays mais il faut qu'il y ait un
meilleur contrôle de l'ensemble de ces
sites c'est un élément important
deuxièmement il est important aussi que
les responsables de l'islam qu'il
s'agisse des des autorités religieuses
ou qu'il s'agissent des des chefs d'État
s'engagent très fortement
contre cette dérive qui est celle de de
l'islam utilisé par un certain nombre de
groupes terroristes merci beaucoup merci
l liomarie d'avoir été en direct avec
nous euh alors si vous nous rejoignez
l'assaut a été donné dans les deux
prises d'otage à Dammartin en Gouel où
étai retranchés les frères Kashi les
frères Kashi qui selon l'Agence France
Presse ont été tué dans cet assaut alors
que l'otage qu'il détenait a été libéré
et tindemne et puis vous le voyez sur
ces images en direct de la porte de
Vincenne où l'assaut a également été
donné il y a quelques minutes selon
l'Agence France press plusieurs otages
ont été libéré on le voit Jean-Marc
Bayol vous devez nous quitter he dans
quelques minutes juste avant est-ce que
vous pouvez nous commenter ces dernières
images visiblement les véhicules de
secours quittent cette ce supermarché où
étent retenus les otages qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire bah les les
ambulance prennent les blessés éventuels
la les lieux vont être
euh sécuriser à l'intérieur du
supermarché pour que les policiers
techniques et scientifiques puissent
faire leurs constatation dans de de de
bonnes conditions et voilà les choses
vont revenir à la normale nous n'avons
pas le le le résultat de ce qui s'est
passé à l'intérieur contrairement à à
l'intervention du du 77 pour l'instant
visiblement sonelon les informations que
nous poss c'est Don et on va garder
encore le conditionnel le le forcet de
la porte de Vincen lui aussi euh a été
tué dans dans l'assaut voilà bon écoutez
je j'aurai le même commentaire que tout
à l'heure j'attends vraiment par contre
avec impatience euh est-ce queil y a eu
des blessés parmi nos collègues et puis
est-ce que parmi les otages euh il n'y a
pas eu d'autres victimes que celle dont
on avait déjà entendu parler tout à
l'heure mais qui je le répète l'ont été
à l'occasion de l'assaut par les les les
les terroristes en en en à 13h deux
policiers du Raid auraient été par
contre été blessés sérieusement por de
vcen ce sont aussi les informations que
l'on a via les réseaux sociaux on va
encore rester prudent mais si c'est le
cas euh évidemment là encore les forces
de l'ordre payent un tribut assez lourd
alors on va rester imprudent sur les
informations des réseaux sociaux en
revance l'Agence France p confirme à
l'instant que les deux suspects les deux
frères Kashi sont sortis en tirant sur
les forces de l'ordre à damartin angouel
pas d'autres
informations on imagine l'assut a été
très dur à Saint-Martin angouel
Jean-Marc Bayol B à partir moment où il
cette information serait confirmée ça
veut dire détermination un peu comme
Mera rappelez-vous he qui a tiré
plusieurs reprises en direction des
forces de en sachant de toute façon
voilà en sachant que de toute façon il y
resterait donc bon voilà encore une
similitude qui prouve toute la
difficulté de de l'appréhension de de ce
type d'individu et et et encore une fois
si si l'information confirme comme vous
le disiez de collègues qui seraient du
raid qui seraient blessé bon voilà c'est
c'est c'est toujours trop et bon voilà
en tout cas information à prendre avec
des information non confirmé parag bon
toute façon les les policiers sont
aguéris professionnel mais le risque
existe et il existe pour des
professionnels sur genre d'intervention
mais aussi pour les policiers qui
assurent la sécurité publique tous les
jours je rappelle message que je vis
faire passer au CEN on est les gardiens
de la paix et c'est quand même le mot
qu'il faut rappeler peut-être qu'on'est
pas toujours apprécié parce que on
réprime mais franchement je crois qu'on
a déterminé soit les services
d'investigation de renseignement mais
aussi d'intervention qu'on était des
républicains dévoués à à la nation et et
jusqu'au péril de notre vie et je crois
vraiment qu'il faut rester dans dans
cette unité et surtout ne pas polémiquer
que ça soit aujourd'hui ou demain vous
disiez vous n'êtes pas toujours appressé
les les circonstances de ces derniers
jours montre que les Français sont ont
exprimé beaucoup de gratitude envers les
forces de police hein oui non mais voilà
il faut c'est souvent le cas dans ce
genre de situation nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que on ne prenne pas que
ces ces extrêmes pour nous nous
reconnaître notre notre dévouement et et
notre passion de notre métier on veut
que ça soit au quotidien et et qu'à
chaque instant un risque peut exister et
que la population le prenne en compte
faut pas se trou se tromper d'ennemis
aujourd'hui c'est là aussi une des
évolutions des choses merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc bayot je sais que vous devez
nous quitter merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et d'avoir commenté en direct
sur notre plateau ces deux assauts
donnés donc à Saint-Martin enouel et à
la porte de Vincenne où les deux prises
d' Tage sont donc maintenant terminé
merci beaucoup et on va rejoindre tout
de suite Faustine saint-jeiès pour les
dernières informations sur ce qui se
passe actuellement sur ces deux prises
d'otage merci oui deux fronts qui ont
l'air d'être terminés alors les deux
suspects de l'assaut de l'attaque à
Charlie Hebdo ont été tué dans l'assaut
qui a été donné à dam Martin l'otage a
été libéré il serait sain et sauf les
correspondants sur place ont entendu des
coups de feu très forts apparemment les
terroristes auraient tiré le GIGN a
répliqué un des membres du GIGN est
blessé mais selon nos confrères de Repin
ces jours ne sont pas en danger autre
dénouement heureux cette fois-ci porte
de 20 scènes l'assaut a été donné quasi
simultanément entre les deux fronts pour
le GIGN quelques instants à quelques
instants près en fait Coulibali serait
décédé selon nos confrères du journal Le
Monde et une deuxième personne un
deuxième attaquant aurait été interpellé
là aussi les otages sont en train d'être
libéré ils sont libres à l'heure où je
vous parle c'est la fin sans doute d'une
journée très intense je vous le rappelle
la prise d'otage à dint Martin a
commencé ce matin à 9h et celle à la
porte de Vincenne environ à
13h merci beaucoup Faustine pour ces
toutes dernières informations et on
repart tout de suite porte de Vincenne
retrouver Thomas sou porte de Vincen où
l'assaut et Ben est bien terminé hein
Thomas ah oui l'assaut qui a été donné
il y a une vingtaine de minutes selon
les premières informations le preneur
d'otage serait mort et les otages
seraient libres les otages qui ont couru
à l'extérieur juste après la prise
d'assaut on ne sait toujours pas on ne
connaît toujours pas le nombre de
blessés que ce soit chez les forces de
l'ordre ou chez les otages vous le voyez
juste derrière moi le quartier est
encore bouclé évidemment il y a beaucoup
de secours derrière moi et on entend
également les surenes ambulances qui
sont très nombreuses ici dans le
quartier de la porte de Vincen à Paris
le quartier encore bouclé et les
habitants qui ne peuvent pas encore
rentrer chez eux en tout cas dans le
périmètre juste derrière moi merci
beaucoup Thomas pour ces dernières
informations et vous n'hésitez bien sûr
pas à intervenir he dès qu'il se passe
des choses du côté de la porte de
Vincenne alors Michel Faustin le disait
il y a quelques minutes c'est la fin
d'une journée très éprouvante ou un
véritable soulagement c'est a un mot
peut-être qu'on retiendra ce soir aussi
c'est ce mot c'est soulagement parce que
il y avait une tension très forte depuis
48h depuis ses attaques à Charlie Hebdo
et puis évidemment toute cette journée
qui a été très très dur pour l'ensemble
des Français qui on imagine sont rester
rivés sur les informations toute la
journée donc beaucoup de tension et
c'est un vrai ouf de soulagement c'est
vrai c'est ce mot qui revient parce que
il y a il y a c'est une véritable peur
qui s'était installé sur la France et et
aujourd'hui grâce certainement au
travail des forces de l'ordre travail de
l'exécutif qu'il faut souligner aussi on
a mis fin à cette traque les terroristes
ont été tués et aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être la seule chose qu'on va
retenir aussi c'est que on a peut-être
mis fin à cette cellule évidemment on ne
sait pas s'il y a d'autres personnes qui
courent encore tout simplement il y a
des questions qui vont commencer à se
poser à partir d'jourd'hui et le fait
que les terroristes éent été tués nous
empêchera peut-être de savoir si
d'autres personnes courent encore sur
c'est un peu ce qui avait êté reproché
entre guillemets bien sûr au raid lors
de l'affire M les avaent tué aussi
Mohamed Mera et c'est vrai que l'exemple
de laffire ma on s'était dit queon avait
pas retenu les leçons et que c'est vrai
que à l'époque de Laffer ma on aurait
souhaité pouvoir que la justice puisse
uvrer face à à à Mohamed Mera et là il
en va de même pour les farquashi ou pour
la la personne qui a été tuée porte de
Vincen on nen saura pas plus pour le
moment mais simplement faut rester en
veille car comme le rappelit notamment
manuel Vals il y a 24 heures il n'y a
pas de risque zéro en matière de
terrorisme ça veut dire que la France
peut rester sous la menace on a été
frappé attaqué depuis 48 he il ne faut
pas exclure qu'il y ait d'autres
personnes qui soient actives on ne sera
pas pour l'instant simplement il faut
rester très très vigilant alors que
l'Agence France Presse dit à l'instant
que dans l'assaut donné por de Versen un
preneur d'otage a été neutralisé euh
donc euh tué euh c'est les dernières
informations qui nous proviennent de
neutralisé veut dire tuer hein qui nous
proviennent c'est du c'est du langage
plutôt plus policier mais c'est vrai que
neutraliser on imagine que la personne a
été abattu voilà les dernières
informations qui nous proviennent à
l'instant de l'Agence France Presse et
visiblement aussi euh quelques blessés
du côté de des forces de l'ordre Adam
Martin visiblement il y a aussi une
personne militaire du GIGN qui a été
touché euh deux personnalités deux
hommes du Raid qui aurent été touchés
aussi p Deen on a aussi une pensée pour
les forces de l'ordre qui il faut
l'admettre ont fait un travail énorme
depuis 48 heur qui ont été mobilisés sur
la France entière et je pense qu'il y a
un coup de chapeau à faire aussi aux
forces de l'ordre ce soir c'est une
réussite hein Michel malgré le fait he
évidemment qu'il y ait des morts que les
preneurs d'otage ét tué c'est quand même
est-ce qu'on peut parler de réussite euh
pour les forces de l'ordre pour les
hommes du Raid les hommes du GN les
hommes ont été neutralisés donc
forcément c'est une réussite cela
n'empêche évidemment pas de se poser des
questions sur comment on n pas été
capable de les neutraliser avant ça
c'est vrai qu'on va forcément se poser
la question cette question s'est posée
depuis ce matin comment est-il possible
qu'avec le matériel utilisé aujourd'hui
on nit pas pu les les rattraper les
traquer plus facilement mais ça ça reste
évidemment ça restera un mystère et et
ça sera aussi les simpnelles questions
qui vont se poser parce qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui il y a des questions très
politiques qui vont se poser Michel
aliarie tout à l'heure que on av au
téléphone se poser cette question sur
l'arsenal législatif qui a été main de
fois main de fois retouché avec des lois
qui ont été votées ces derniers temps
une loi qui a été votée il y a 2 mois
mais qui n'a pas encore été euh validée
par et qui n'est pas encore passé
directement dans les faits euh donc il y
a aussi cet arsenal législatif qui
pourrait permettre et on en discuté tout
à l'heure avec notre invité qui pourrait
permettre dans un futur d'aider aussi
les forces de l'ordre doit avoir un
accès directement sur ceux qui sortent
des prisons notamment sur ces
terroristes qui qui vont faire le djihad
en Syrie et qui reviennent également où
on arriverait à faire récupérer plus
d'informations sur eux bref ces lois
différentes lois qui ont été votées on
verra si l'arsenal législatif nous
permet aujourd'hui d'aller plus loin
simplement il y a encore quelques
questions qui vont se poser en terme
d'efficacité de de ce monde du
renseignement alors que selon les
dernières informations Michel le preneur
d'otage à la porte Vincen n'aurait
peut-être pas été tué donc neutr iser ne
signifie pas forcément tuer on va attend
ça pourrait permettre à la justice pour
cette fois-ci donc on va revenir un
petit peu sur ce qu'on disait et c'est
important donc de d'avoir les
informations précises c'est que ça
pourrait permettre à la justice de
l'entendre aux forces de l'ordre
également d'activer un petit peu tous
les réseaux autour de ces personnalités
car on sait aujourd'hui que ce les
réseaux de ces hommes-là travaillent
depuis des années entre l'Algérie le
Yémen on sait qu'il se sont entraînés du
côté du Yémen et qu'il s'étaient préparé
qu'il se euh
qu'ils étaient membres de Al-Qaïda
yemmen c'est ce qu'il disait on
l'entendait crier sur sur ses images
quand ils ont attaqué Charlie Hebdo et
même auprès des des gens qui à qui il
volaient leur voiture à qui il prenaient
en otage il disait dites bien que nous
sommes d'Al-Qaïda au Yémen ça veut dire
que il y aura un travail très très
précis du monde de ce renseignement que
ce soit du monde de la police mais aussi
au monde de la justice et c'est très
bien c'est une excellente nouvelle
évidemment si le forconet a pu être
arrêté ou en tout cas blessé et être
arrêté dans la foulée on va attendre he
bien sûr Michel he d'avoir plus
d'information on va surtout rester très
prudent ne donner que les informations
qui viennent de l'Agence France Presse
l'Agence France Presse qui je vous le
disais vient de communiquer à l'instant
une information selon laquelle le
preneur d'otage de la porte de Vincen
aurait été neutralisé on va tout de
suite retrouver Caroline Deschamps
bonjour Caroline pour faire un point sur
la façon dont les réseaux sociaux et
Internet ont accueilli ce dénouement et
bien beaucoup de réactions évidemment
sur les réseaux sociaux et de
félicitations aux forces de l'ordre
Bruno
retaillot je le cite tweet hommage aux
forces de police et de la gendarmerie
c'est ainsi que s'exprime le président
du groupe UMP ici au Sénat suivi par
Roger carucci qui écrit gignn raid
police gendarmerie risque leur vie pour
nous nous défendre pour défendre la
République honneur hommage ne jamais
oublié à gauche Yann brossal adjoint au
maire de Paris écrit grand respect pour
les fonctionnaires de police qui
agissent avec un dévouement et un sens
du service public exemplaire et puis
c'est un ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
aussi qui réagit sur Twitter Paul
killess chaleureuses félicitations aux
forces de sécurité pour leur
professionnalisme et leur efficacité euh
Frédéric juditelli qui fait partie de
l'équipe communication de l'Élysée tweet
que dire à part que les fonctionnaires
du GGN et du Ren sont des héros toute
l'équipe est profondément émue de son
côté à Gilles Boyer le bras droit
d'Alain Jupé écrit il faut avoir foi
dans l'état et puis certains
journalistes rapporte sur Twitter qu'à
la porte de Vincen les gens
applaudissent sur le passage des
ambulants
qui quitte le lieu de la prise d'otage
et puis bien sûr certains tweetos
regrettent que les preneurs d'otage soit
mort puisque comme ça ils ne pourront
pas rendre compte de leurs actes devant
la justice voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
merci beaucoup Caroline pour ce point
complet alors Michell il y a un très
grand moment qui va venir dans les
prochains jours il aura lieu dimanche
une grande manifestation républicaine
qui aura lieu à Paris ouis c'est vrai et
puis c'est vrai que là on est dans le
soulagement Caroline le disait il y a
des applaudissements sur le passage des
ambulances sur les passages des forces
de l'ordre mais on va pas oublier ce qui
s'est passé l'attaque de Charlie Hebdo
c'est 12 morts c'estes nombreux blessés
on va pas l'oublier du coup il y a cet
hommage qui va être rendu dimanche au
cours de cette grande manifestation
popul char 12 morts mais la fusette de
Montrouge un mort la fusette de Vincen
ce matin de morts soit 15 morts en tout
he dans ces attaques nickeles donc on va
pas oublier loin de là et c'est pour ça
que alors c'est vrai que ce sont les les
organis tion politiqu qui ont appelé à
cette manifestation on attend selon les
organisateurs près ou plus d'un million
de personnes ce qui serait une sorte de
Ran Maré populaire et heureusement et
c'est une sorte domommage très important
qui sera rendu on vient de recevoir à
l'instant Michell des images exclusives
des Chaîne Parlementaire image exclusive
qui montre l'assaut qui a eu lieu porte
de 20 scènes l'assaut qui a eu lieu il y
a quelques minutes hein dans cette
superette où un forcenz retenez au moins
un cotage vous le voyez donc en direct
sur ces images C assaut qui a été donné
il y a quelques minutes hein des images
bien sûr qui ne sont pas en direct
l'assut a été donné il y a trois quart
d'heure mais ce sont les forces du Red
évidemment qui interviennent qui ont
réussi à faire sauter la porte d'entrée
de cette hyper cachère qui est juste à
l'entrée du périphérique porte de Vincen
et on les voit juste en rang serré juste
derilleère cette porte prêt à à R rentré
un tir de sommation avec des armes
lourdes et on imagine qu'ils sont
rentrés très très rapidement après pour
récupérer l'otage ou les otages qui
étaient présents sur place voilà des
images exclusives des chaînes
parlementaire sur cet assaut qui a donc
eu lieu porte de vin scenes il y a
maintenant une grosse demi-heure euh
alors des informations contradictoires
hein bien sûr sur issu de cet assaut
selon plusieurs médias là vous entendez
des explosions
des et au nombre de coups de feu on a pu
imaginer que c'était assez violent he
que vous entendez tous ces nombreux
coups de feu en rafale qui ont été
donnés on imagine que l'attaque a été
assez violente à l'intérieur également
et les forces du Red qui interviennent
très très rapidement
après on entend aussi beaucoup de cris
hein qui proviennent cementinttérieur ou
extérieur de
peur ça permet aussi au force de l'ORD
de faire sortir les otages
certainement c'est rare quand on peut
voir ces images là en tout cas pour on
sait que les médias ont été tenus à
l'écart de toutes les interventions que
ce soit Adam Martin ou porte de Vincen
il y a un cordon de sécurité très
lointain pour les médias et c'est c'est
très impressionnant de de pouvoir voir
voir avec quelques minutes après ces
images peut-être appeler le bilan aussi
de cette
opération voilà vous le
grâce aux images exclusives des chaînes
parlementaires vous avez donc pu vivre
ce qu'il s'est passé il y a une grosse
demi-heure maintenant porte de Vincen où
l'assaut a été donné je le disais he
Michel des informations contradictoires
he quant à quant à l'issue de cette on
va rester très prudent plusieurs médias
annoncent que le tireur a été abattu
l'Agence France Presse euh dit que le
tireur a été neutralisé euh nous allons
bien sûr rester très prudent hein voilà
donc pour ces imag euh exclusive de cet
assaut euh donné dans cette superette
porte de Vincen euh on le disait hein
Michell on parlait de ce temps fort qui
aura lieu dimanche alors qui va bien sûr
réunir tous les Français mais pas
seulement euh puisque mariaaroy vient
d'annoncer euh à l'instant qu'il serait
présent dimanche également ou de
nombreuses personnalités du monde
politique européen du monde entier qui
vont certainement venir pour parce que
c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé en
France a secoué le monde entier pourquoi
parce que c'est la liberté de la presse
qui a été touchée parce que ce sont les
forces de l'ordre qui ont été touchées
et à partir du moment où touche à cette
forme de liberté qui représente la
France du coup ça fait un mouvement de
secouse et tout le monde entier s vous
avez vu toutes ces images de de de de
gens mobilisés qui se sont réunis dans
les rues avec des bougies je suis
Charlie un petit peu partout cette image
que l'on a vu parcourir le monde entier
de l'Australie jusqu'en Chine jusqu'au
Brésil également donc on imagine que
cette manifestation aura une
répercussion très très importante dans
le monde entier c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale vous avez donc suivie
en direct sur les chaînes parlementaires
la fin de ces deux prises d'otage porte
de Vincenne et à damartin angouel je
vous rappelle les dernières informations
Adam Martin angouel les deux frères
Kashi les deux preneurs d'otage les deux
suspects dans l'affaire de l'attentat
contre Charlie Hebdo ont été tués et on
l'apprend à l'instant par l'Agence
France press que le tireur et le preneur
d'otage à la porte de Vincen a également
été tué hein amedi Koulibali les trois
preneurs d'otage ont donc été tué lors
de ces assauts nous allons bien sûr
revenir sur toutes ces informations dans
un peu moins de trois quart d'heure dans
le journal de Marie bremau merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi très bonne soirée
sur les jeunes
parlementaire